hundreds of thousands are on the move
across Syria and Iraq many are
struggling to live in refugee camps such
as here in northern Iraq under desperate
conditions but they are still better off
here than in areas controlled by Islamic
state militia we were under siege from
the Islamic state and then government
forces moved in that's when the air
strike started that's why we're here the
atrocities committed by the group have
shocked the world these images show more
than a hundred bodies allegedly captured
Syrian soldiers slaughtered by is the
pictures were taken from an internet
video posted by the group the
international community is struggling to
forge a response US President Barack
Obama says he doesn't yet know how best
to fight Islamic state last week any
successful strategy though also needs
strong regional partners I'm encouraged
so far that countries in the region
countries that don't always agree on
many things increasingly recognized the
primacy of the threat that ISIL poses to
all of them government briefing the
United Nations Security Council the un
deputy humanitarian chief expressed
alarm grave human rights violations have
become the norm in Syria parties to the
conflict are oblivious of their
obligations to protect civilians and
abide by international humanitarian law
as they continue to commit terrible
crimes against civilians young and old
women and men it's not clear whether
such appeals will influence the Security
Council which has been unable to agree
on a serious strategy since the conflict
there began